you're a father of four as i know when
you see images like those on the front
page of say the daily mirror this
morning where a little girl
has got her contact details
written on her back in case her parents
are murdered by putin and his henchmen
how much does that strengthen your
resolve to have him removed from office
i think it it strengthens the result for
all of us and what we're seeing
unfolding now in ukraine is
absolutely appalling these atrocities
we're now sadly seeing almost daily on
our tv screens and and the image you
just talked of you know when i first saw
that image i think yesterday you know it
could have been my daughter it could be
anyone's daughter their son and just to
think that's what parents are having to
do
in ukraine right now because of the
choice that vladimir putin has made and
we should never forget this is a choice
this was not a a a war for any other
reason than than something that vladimir
putin had just chosen to do and and we
will uh continue to help ukraine in
every way that we can whether that's
military support whether it's with
support for sanctions on russia and
humanitarian support and does that
include regime change
look
it's ultimately up to
the russian people about
the leadership of their country but i do
think
the prime minister our prime minister
was right yesterday to appeal directly
uh to the russian people in the way that
he did yeah i know a lot of russians i'm
sure many of people listening do and
they are
the vast majority they're just ordinary
decent compassionate people and do they
really want to see this war unfolding
especially in the way that it is
in in their name and if there's an
opportunity for them to to
to to you make their feelings heard to
their own government and i hope that
they listen to to boris johnson and
others
and react
okay you're in a hospital today of
course because you want to talk to us
about the hike in national insurance
how on earth can it be a fair tax it
does seem to unfairly tax those who can
at least afford uh to fund this this is
going to be used for health and social
care levy of course isn't it but but
aren't there better ways of doing that
well let me just first say what the what
this new levy does it kicks in today the
new health and social care levy it's all
of the funding raised from it is going
to go towards the extra 39 billion
pounds we're going to put in over the
next three years into health and social
care it's going to pay in the nhs for
activity levels that are some hundred
and thirty percent of pre-pandemic it's
going to be nine million more scans
tests and and procedures meaning people
will get seen a lot earlier why is any
of this necessary whether it's for
health or social care it's because of
the impact of the pandemic we know it's
unprecedented it's been the biggest
challenge in our lifetime and the impact
of that is going to continue for many
years you asked me about uh the fairness
of it is you know when we spend money on
public services whether it's nhs or
anything else for that matter the money
can only come from two sources it's
either it's you raise it uh directly
from people today that's through taxes
or uh you borrow it which is essentially
you're asking the next generation to pay
for it i think it is right that we pay
for what we are going to use as a
country but we do it in a in a fair way
and this levy
the way it's being raised is the the top
15 percent of earners will pay almost 50
percent and i think it's the right way
to do this if you were chancellor and
you're still chancellor and you saw half
a million kids falling into absolute
poverty because of your measures would
you think twice
i think look i am not chancellor i'm the
health secretary my job is to is to make
sure that we're doing everything we can
to recover from the pandemic when it
comes to health and and social care but
when it comes to the treasury and the
chancellor and the support that's been
provided i think that the focus is
absolutely right when it comes to the
cost of living i don't think anyone out
there listening thinks that the
government can mitigate a worldwide
inflation crisis for in every way for
every single person but what government
can do is support those that need it
most and the actions that we've taken on
energy bills for example with nine
billion pounds of support uh on on the
new hardship fund for local authorities
for those that are most vulnerable and
also most important of all of supporting
work you know the best way out of
poverty for anyone is in work we've now
in this country we've got one of the
lowest unemployment rates that this
country has ever seen the lowest uh
youth unemployment rate we've had for
decades and that doesn't happen by
accident it's happening because of the
policies of this government and we're
supporting those people in work with
more tax cuts okay
as health secretary then as you as you
pointed out to me is it acceptable to
administer
an electric shock
to someone who feels that they are in
the wrong body
uh no i don't think so no no of course
not so why has that been removed from
the bill for the queen's speech so
transgender people would still uh
undergo that sort of con conversion
therapy which sounds inhumane to me
well when it comes to conversion therapy
it is absolutely right as the government
has said that we we ban you the
so-called you know conversion therapy
for lgb people when it comes to trends i
do think that we need to be more careful
you you ask me again as health secretary
uh in my mind is for example is the
recent report by dr hillary cash she's
one of the
most experienced pediatricians in this
country she just published an interim
report just a few weeks ago and she
talked about
how
children and young people
when they when they
say they have gender dysphoria it is
right for medical experts to to be able
to question that and to determine that
what the cause might be is it a genuine
case of uh gender identity dysphoria or
could it be that that individual is
suffering from some child sex abuse for
example or could it be linked to
bullying so i think it is it is right to
take the approach that we have which is
to ban uh good conversion therapy for
lgp
lgb but but to take a a much more sort
of sensitive approach when it comes to
trans
yeah but again my question is does that
include allowing people to have an
electric shock because they feel they're
in the wrong body if it sounds inhumane
to me no it doesn't no it no it doesn't
and there are also already you know
there are many laws in place uh that
that you should prevent anything of that
type of anything part of the therapy
isn't it it can be dangerous should that
be against the law
well it
i don't think that anyone should be
administered with electric shock for for
the reasons that you're saying and uh
there are laws in place that would
protect i think i think that would count
as abuse and it would already be against
the law
okay um thanks very much for
clarification on that i'm sure that will
develop further throughout the course of
the day but i do want to ask you if i
may about um covid and the new
uh guidelines that were being given
apparently there's nine separate
symptoms now as far as kovid is
concerned that you should be checking
for before you go to work one of them
includes um there they go one of them
includes uh tiredness um or a headache
um
if you've got tiredness or a headache
would you still go to work
um no if i had
first of all i think is absolutely right
as we learn more about covid and also as
as we come across new variants
that our experts your update the
symptoms list there are still three
major symptoms but it's right that
others have been added just to give
people you know a bit more information
about what may or may not be covered now
just taking any one or two of those
you've just picked uh
headaches and tiredness does it in
itself
say that you've got covered it you may
have but especially if you've got some
of the more uh the the the where we have
more information so for example if you
have a a sense of uh
loss of your your taste uh or if you
have a cough that's developed that you
didn't have before or if you have a
fever those are the three main symptoms
people should look out for to answer
your question directly if i had a
headache or uh i was feeling a bit tired
um it depends how tired i felt uh i
might want to get some more sleep
and if i had a bit of a headache i'd
first reach for the neurofen
uh
as a secretary of state i'm sure you're
pretty tired almost all of the time very
busy job i'm sure um talk to me about
kierstama
he has said that despite what the prime
minister told us he presided over
widespread criminality in his office
talking about
partygate
what
should happen as far as party gate fines
are concerned uh dominic raab has said
that it was what happened that was
against the law
do you agree that the prime minister
presided over widespread criminality in
his office
what i agree with is i think what we
have all learnt over the last few months
is that there were
certainly there are events that took
place in in downing street during the
height of the pandemic that needed to
and are being properly investigated they
should be investigated by the proper
authorities and that's exactly what's
happening uh the police are continuing
their investigations as i understand it
but this is really a matter for the
police i don't think it's appropriate
for ministers any minister including
myself to to talk about what the police
may or may not do well they've already
issued 20 fines and when we were talking
about kobe did want to answer my
question directly so if i could ask this
one again please did the prime prince
did the prime minister forgive me
preside over widespread criminality in
his office
well when you ask me about kobe that's a
matter that relates directly uh to me
and my my job uh and it's not uh
something for an independent authority
when you're asking about uh matters of
um
of the law uh this is rightly in a in a
in a democracy like accounts
it is a matter for the police no
nonsense
police have already issued 20 fines come
on we know what the police think i'm
asking you whether you agree with the
police that there's been widespread
caught down
i know
i know what the police have uh published
i know nothing more or less than that uh
we know about the number of fines i have
no idea uh who has received those fines
uh or not uh but i i you know i just
hesitate to comment on this
further know who's received at least one
of the five because it was the woman
yeah we'd know come on minister we know
that at least one person who was in
charge of ethics in downing street at
the time received a fine because she
told us that she did we know that 19
other fines have been issued as well on
20 separate occasions more to come the
law was broken in downing street ergo
the prime minister presided over law
breaking in downing street
we will we will learn more about this
short from the police there will also be
a final report uh from sue gray again an
independent report and i think that's
what i'll wait for before i say anything
further okay thanks for joining us i
know you've got a busy day ahead thank
you for taking the time to speak to us
on the program thank you